hello hi
[Music]
um hey yes I'm sure so uh
please
type
before I really like go into the top
that usually I ask people like well well
you know the height of the talk you come
here so definitely you
you're not found of writing tests right
so what is the most difficult part of
writing tests so what makes you not like
what I think writing tests right
any ideas
examples wow that's really good I really
feel you because there's also something
I'm going to tell you later
okay
I think I launch a lot of lots of things
uh sometimes you kind of forget to wait
for the test uh because you know if you
are good like if you want to make your
cocoa coverage the test coverage to be
like high right you if you write a lot
of tests and sometimes it just get too
messy because there's too many tests and
you have to try to cover all grounds
let's talk about a couple of grounds you
need a lot of examples right so that's
exactly what uh the other person said
like right thinking about what to test
think about the test cases think about
what example to give to this as that
really tripped me over so
uh so hypothesis probably can't help you
with like employing the code right
you're saying don't mess up the the you
know the the path your code try to like
you know you you can find a solution or
something probably like you know you
have to eat meat Supply somewhere you
know
and things like that but a hypothesis to
help you with organizing a test
um where you see why in a bit and also
help you
to think of well not really help you
think of test case boarding with using
performance is you don't have to think
of writing test cases so how do we
achieve that so that's like the topic of
this talk right how to avoid all the
pain of writing tests so uh first of all
I would like to introduce myself because
like it's the first time I'm speaking in
this city in New York
um so uh I'm sure hello I work anaconda
and I love open source project I've been
involved in different open source
product in the past that's why I do a
lot of testing and some of them really
like it's a pain
also I organize events I also organize
like not this year but in the past I
organize I did a global I also help I
did in London so it's my local high data
I'm based in London UK so yeah it's very
rare for me to be here so I'm like so
happy
um on my conference which I will tell
you at the end of The Talk
sorry I'm too excited
oh what do I stream online uh I've been
but not now doing the pandemic
fast
um so
have you heard of property-based testing
yeah some of you some of you
um
so what is property based testing
well it's a term right like you're
are you creating it like just you know
to to sound smart you know
so
um to make it simple so um we test like
um there are actually multiple ways of
testing
so uh you may have been told that you
have to write unit tests right you have
to um
test each function each method
frequently
so
um
I would draw a line here and I have two
uh way of doing it so
what is test by sample one is test by
property so
I would say that normally
normally
how are your test is test by example so
when you think of uh what to test so you
have to think of past cage right
we should have to provide example for
the test we have to imagine what that
variable could be or the input of the
function could be so we have to provide
example
the other thing is the property based
testing which
uh we don't have to think of what it
could be it's what it is
so for example if you have a function
the input is two integers
so the inputs are two integers that's
what it is is you don't have to think of
oh so what is an integer is it is zero
can I test do I have to test zero do I
test negative and then just positive or
negative black has a very large integer
so you don't have to think of that it's
just given
so because of that uh if we test by
sample we have to think of all the test
cases again like the thought process
right you don't have zero or not test
minus and that has like very big numbers
uh wait break
uh so yeah find Edge paste by yourself
but with property-based testing
uh those work actually has been lifted
has been uh done from the strategy in
the library so I'll talk more about
strategy in a bit but that's how that's
why you don't have to think of what
example to give
the other thing is The Edge case right
we all know that Ash case are the things
that we have to test because that's
usually where we overlooked where we
like oh forgot to test
a zero right so and then like you just
divide the number and then oh divide by
silver error uh when usually the user
find it on themselves you kind of feel a
little embarrassed that you forgot to
test the zero things
um but we're probably face testing
because the strategy has been used so
many times and the I would say it's like
bulletproof but like the the chances are
you having this it's way less
then you think of example yourself so
how does hypothesis make that happen it
sounds like magic I don't have to think
of anything
um so in hypothesis first of all we use
those decorators one of the most common
way to introduce hypothesis to your test
is to use
even the given is decorator provided by
hypothesis that it act as an entry point
so it will modify your test into a
property based test
and then you also need strategy so
strategy is basically the heart of the
property-based testing it basically
um describes a
how to generate the test case so this is
why you don't have to think of it
yourself because the strategy is already
written by someone and it's helping you
because it has been used like all the
time so
I I hope the strategy is going to be
like kind of more fruit than like what
you kind of think of a few use case uh
test case yourself
so security is going to generate the
test data for you
for you so this is a 101 example of how
a hypothesis has could work so this is a
very simple code that is uh I think it's
an example from somewhere some Library
other libraries that
basically it's doing a very simple thing
it got a string and then this encode
functions of encoded right
and there's another function that's the
code so decode what has been encoded so
we'll go back to what it was
so simple right so we test it we use
hypothesis so um like I talked about
before we need a given you should
decorated the act as an entry point to
your test
so given we have to import it and then
we have the important strategy
since the end code function is encoding
a string so it's text so the strategy
that we use is the text strategy
so we import those things and then just
add the decoration like that here it is
a given and then we have one input the
input is a text that's how it is look
like so uh the whole thing went like
this for a simple set a line of code uh
also the the way we tested is what we
call the round trip so because we have a
pair function encoding because so if you
have a string you encode it and then
decode it again you should come back to
what it was so this is what it's testing
right
oh good so how about we tried it so
let's let's try it before we moved on so
sorry I just want this one okay still a
bit funky okay
so what I've done is that I've already
done some prep work I have created a my
code.pi so let's have a look at my
code.i
so sorry about it's not highlighting I
should add some plug in there that bear
with me is basically the same code as I
showed you in the slides before so we
have an encoder and decoding but that's
my code so I want to test it right
so I've written the test so I copy and
paste the test in the test.pi so let's
clear it up first and then let's have a
look
so wow it's very loud
yeah just name it randomly sorry
um yeah so it's just import the code and
then test it right
before let's run it so I have so in this
environment you can see it's called demo
hypothesis which is like a hypothesis
inside so I use Pi test so let's use Pi
test and then test the code
oops doing this again okay
whoop
huh
we have an error
but don't worry uh I'm exactly this so
what happened
uh I know it's a bit difficult to see
but maybe someone's sitting in the front
already know what's going on
no maybe it's too difficult to see I
know but the red thing is like basically
hiding in the background so uh it says
to the the era says local variable
character reference before assignment
and then the important thing is that
like after that it says that it fails on
a test case that when interest rate is
empty
so
we found a Nash case that it fails
um yeah when infrastring is empty then
we have a problem
so as you can see what we have done is
just that we write separate line of code
we haven't think of what cases to test
but we already found Edge case that we
may have to fix in our code
um so this is the power of hypothesis
that we don't have to think of like what
strength to test do we test string of
the length one string of Moon Shoes
empty string and it will just find all
the case we used to test and it will
help you to find things like this right
good
um let me go back to the slice
your cook
so
um
I oh there's already a question do you
mind if you hold on until the end okay
yeah
so
um
I know
for those of you come to Pi data New
York you're interested in like
scientific program because like you know
data science also use a lot of
scientific things so what I talk about
scientific back here is actually another
pie in pandas
so uh in Empire so they're actually why
I talk about this in this conference is
that I think now hypothesis got a lot of
um
it use because it has the user in mind
right so like kind of think of
uh people who use numpy or pandas uh the
other strategy may not be very useful
for them because numpygo is untype
because it's on d-type that is like some
integers or you know unsite integers of
these things right scientific scalers
and also arrays we have numpy arrays and
stuff so
uh don't worry hypothesis got you
covered
um but the thing is because hypothesis
want to keep its Library large it's not
all users are using numpy like us okay
so you may have to install hypothesis
again if you already have it or if you
have any side offices you know we're
going to use numpy you can eat some
hypothesis like this the difference is
that it will install that non-bike numpy
extra for you
so um so it will uh so you can use what
I'm going to talk about in this slide in
the next slide so
um after you have it you saw it like
this so you will have some extra things
uh the hypothesis got extra not popping
so uh you can use the strategy there so
if you look at the documentation you
will see that
um there are a lot of strategy provided
for some like non-ply specific types for
example there are the token maybe
actually I can share this thing
yes so
so there are a lot of different types
that you can see here they are like uh
for example they are raised numpy arrays
so now like
uh you know in in a python object you
can test like oh the text test the the
list but it doesn't apply to numpy
arrays so now you can have you know
hiring strategies that it will work
um
it's just examples showing you how this
work and
is also the other scalar types like for
example you can have the integer inside
materialism so these are built extra for
numpy users
so you can have some extra strategy to
help you because otherwise it's kind of
quite useless right yeah all these you
know numpy things that actually well I
can't I don't know what strategy to make
it work well you have to come up with
your own strategy which is a bit more
work than what you're expecting right
let's go back here
um but on top of that right so we do you
think like over numpy is cool but I am
handling data I'm like cleaning data and
stuff so I use Panda more than numpy's
we also got you covered don't worry so
it's the same thing you have to install
the extra uh you know that uh pandas
actually use numpy another Hood so it's
more or less the same thing actually
like this
and then we have the extra stuff on the
pandas
and what it provides is the palace index
Panda series and tendency effect for
Palestinian frame is well we all know
right it's like the DF right you know
like we have all this like shorthand
that only data scientists understand
like PD is tenders and APS numpy and DF
is a different version so the data frame
so actually it's kind of the same thing
uh you can also find a strategy for it
very easily
um also series uh series is basically
the bearing block of data frame so we
can view each column as a series and
head index index is like uh it's quite
important for the Instagram as well
because that's how you find all the
columns and all the
rows
so at those are also available so
you may like for example you never
thought that was going to be used from
now with this information you know maybe
I can try it on my Pandora station frame
to see like you can find on HK so
there's an empty data frame I don't know
like maybe you have to put in the shape
of it I forgot like how it looks like
but against in the documentation if you
go back here
wait I do believe the the array you have
to put in the shape
of it but like for example you also have
the pandas
so if you just go scroll all the way
down there's some appendix this is
available let's look at maybe the data
frame they happen
it even has the columns right you have
it so even like I want to see if this
work for what is like a columns so you
can try that
um
so yeah so you can beat that I'm not
going to go into the details otherwise
like we're going to be reading it
together
rest of the top so let's go back here
and
sorry I'm not I've been using Mac for so
long but I'm still like finding quite
drinking okay
um
so so far so good right so far we we
know that there's a hypothesis we have
things that like we could test with like
we have a string we can test it with the
strategy that's text we have a numpy
array we can test it with a strategy
that's like all from the the the array
type of this thing but
volume I'm really lazy
but that is even too much for me I have
to think of what strategy to use right
it's too much
it's too much I hate doing that so what
am I gonna do
so first of all a piece of advice even
if you're super lazy it's always good to
type your code because
uh it will also avoid making a lot of
mistakes but at the same time it really
helps you here so uh
do you know that hypothesis in
hypothesis there's something called a
ghost writer that actually literally
write the test for you so you don't you
don't even need to write a test so if
you're that lazy that really help you so
what a Ghostwriter do in hypothesis is
that it will use typing as a hint so
that's why I said typing is important
here later on I'll explain why what
happened if you don't type your code but
if you have typed your code
um
how much this will pick the right
strategy uh for you from the type of
your parameter so again some sometimes
things are quite straightforward for
example if you have a string you just
pick the tech strategy if you have a
numpy array you will pick the right
strategy for you if you have the number
extra
so it's
um so with the typing because you have
tell the program that what type your
variable should be
uh Ghostwriter will pick that up and
write the test with the right strategy
for you
now so it's a cni tool actually so uh
actually you can use it
um in a python code but I think the most
powerful thing is to use it in a CI tool
so I will show you a bit of how it could
be done in a in a second I'm just going
to finish this slice first
to auto
yeah also there's like uh do you know
the formative black yes yes yes yeah now
everybody is black no like two years ago
it's still new but now everybody use it
um so if you have black install it's not
a hard requirement but if you have the
black in store The Ghostwriter will
finish writing your code and it will
format the curve for you using black so
if you like the performance that black
provide it will be consistent The Ghost
Writer the test that goes right and
right is gonna follow the same format as
well
so this is how this is how it works it's
just like this so uh let's see how it
works in the in the terminal so whoops
okay
so let's see what this is
right
gzip
oh what happened here so actually this
is color folder I'm like very possible I
don't know what what happened at least
because like you know it's the Alpha
from I was just that's why it's so nice
it's kind of good
it's even color coded
okay anyway oh so this is basically all
the text that generated by The
Ghostwriter so yeah you can see from the
comment here it's maybe a difficult
scene has co-works written by hypothesis
yes it's written by The Ghost Writer
um so what I've done in the CRI is that
I said that I want to write the test for
the module GC so GC for those of you who
have never heard about that before is a
standard Library which means that I come
with your python so you don't have to
Pivot install it you probably will
already have GC so you can run tests for
it
um
so uh this is actually a test right if
what you said it Imports all the
strategy and it gives them from our
homes's it write the test so these are
all like
a hypothesis test right but again it
goes strategy inside and also there are
different way of testing as well that's
why you can see we have a round trip so
there's similar people uh to what we
have done manually before which is like
oh doing a compression and doing
decompressions see if they are the same
um there are also other things like for
some of us which just means that are
going to run the function and see if it
works if there's any error that comes
out
um yeah so it's
it's very
I would say this is covering all of the
tests uh well maybe not all most of the
tests in Json
so um I have not even written a single
line of curve what I've done is just to
type it in my mind so there's actually a
lot of uh
like uh settings you can you can set
so for example here you see that uh
so this is the examples you you put in a
module so uh GC like I said is already
included so you can have that
um
so you can also like run the whole
module but you can accept something for
example I don't want to test all the
errors from RE so you can
skip that you have also pick different
strategy for uh for the for the gospel
there's a different Ghostwriter
strategy there so I'll explain that a
little bit so you can also pick
different ones for example round trip is
the one that will try
um so yeah you can see all this
explanation here but let's go back to
the slides
correct
so
they are actually different uh ghost
writing strategy here
um first you have seen it in the gcip
example it's just kind of run the module
the function in the module to see if it
works or
does it provide any errors so this is
what it does and
the most basic one if you ask me
so but there are other different things
it's more interesting
for example this one
um
just uh means that if you have prior
function to a result it is a definition
um investment result you can apply the
same function to the same to the to the
result of that again but it won't change
so as usual when it has something like a
salt thing so
if you saw something uh it should be
done right if you sort it again it
should not give you something different
otherwise that's random
sorry it should not be very bad so
um for those kind of function you can
test it with that in that Independence
yeah I don't know how to pronounce this
word it's so difficult oh
so you can use this strategy to test
a function like the Sorting algorithm
so round trip which is my favorite you
can see I already use it different types
already when you have a pair function it
will
apply the first one to it and it applies
the second one to it it should go back
to where it was
they are actually in code there are
actually a lot of pairs of functions
like this for example in Json you have
the Jason thumbs and Jason nose uh well
I use that a lot because I had no data
so there's also Jason coming in now so
um it's very good sometimes I write my
own
um function to handle some data handling
like to switch it from one format to the
other and then going back so you're
right there's a pair pair of functions
like this this is super useful when you
don't want to write tests for it you can
just generate a test for it
so the
um oh by the way also go back here
um like when remember when we did a g
set right so uh when we do the gcip
module so we just put in the name of the
module so what The Ghostwriter does is
that it will scan the whole module and
if it's fine two things that the name is
hinted that they appear for example Doms
and those or from something to something
um then it will just automatically apply
round trip to it so in the gcip I think
that was a compressed compressed and
decompressed so the ghost writer already
see those two and know that it's a pair
that you can test it with round trip so
that's how powerful how powerful the
ghost rides is
so uh the other thing we can test is the
equivalent for example you have two
functions you can check whether they
more or less behave the same way
um this is useful especially when you
already have one function that you know
it works for example it's provided from
the center Library like this one here I
made this up myself so
um I want to write a function that uses
the
the mathematics so I will check whether
this is the part of this
so it should if I do it correctly which
I don't think I did here but anyway
um if I do it correctly it should
actually be more or less the same as the
method of power right because I know
that best of power is going to be
correct but I want to write my own
sometimes for different reasons
sometimes you may want to have a speed
up or sometimes you have
you know different reasons that like oh
that's optimized on that code or things
like that you write that you want to
check whether it behaves correctly you
can use a function that you trust to
check it against that one
so there's a lot there's a lot of girls
writer there's actually two more but I
won't dive in the detail here
um someone that tests for a binary
operation
um but because
I don't know about you but I personally
don't write custom binder operation that
often so I'm not going to dive into it I
also use phone so if you use numpy it
also has a new phone to test a review
phone for you I don't buy a review phone
for you so it's useful if you use
notepad but I won't go into the detail
you can check the documentation if you
today
so I already done this bit actually I've
already tried it so I'm not going to
but
or maybe let's
try
for example
I'll try the Json one because like I'll
show you the the round trip right so
what we do is like just hypothesis right
so I do enjoy yourself
oh actually oh actually a few things
actually I I completely forgot I'm still
having jet lag sorry about that
um so this is Json you can see that uh
it does test the the round trip right I
hope it does
there's a lot of things to test actually
in the Json
so yeah round trip so you see thumbs and
lows so it knows that it's a pair I
don't even tell
like those writers that oh there's
thumbs and low in Json please test them
round trip I don't even need to say that
it just have a very smart guess so it
should be
I'm also it has other things for some
there's a an area I should actually
accept like I should skip that but
you know it happens so
yeah so it's it's very cool so uh what I
wanted to try to show you is that since
now I have the the my code right so
so let's have a look again to my code
so this right there's a sound by the
beginning of the talk
um now imagine I don't want to write
wrong test I'm so lazy so what am I
going to do with this what I'm going to
do is to use Ghostwriter so let's look
at this again so
so yeah I have my coat the pie so I have
to treat it like a module so what I'm
going to do is to do just hypothesis
right
my code
yeah I I think my jet lag is really
clicking on me right now I'm so sorry
okay so uh beware that those hyped up
high at the end because it needs
it needs so now I have my code here it
will be like you know
you know a filed
press enter
so this is what the ghost writer
generated in my opinion this is even
better than the code Android because uh
yeah because it's like very very clear
right and also a colorful it's amazing
wow okay so but this is actually more or
less the same thing it's a round trip
test it's testing the code that this the
first thing is to have the input strain
as the input and the second is to use
the resellers which is video Zero and
test it as an input for the second one
and if you've got the value one and if
anyone should go back to what if the
input string should be right
so it's exactly what like what we did
so you can so imagine uh okay so how am
I going to use this now so because this
is generated and it's in the command
line prompts how can I really do it how
am I going to use it so
uh what you can do is to
uh
I believe so this right
uh save this let's name it something
else I don't mess up
I think it's like this okay right so now
I have an extra file say test so uh this
is exactly the what is covered from a
command line poem now I can run it with
high test right so high test and then I
will save testing
so it's exactly the same thing that we
got before
so
if you haven't seen the the the example
like the the demonstration at the
beginning of the talk you will see that
I have run the test without writing the
test
this is what I try to like show that
with hypothesis you don't have to write
a test okay
so uh it's really cool
but I always need to leave you with your
butt something to think about
uh it's nice as if I'm like really kind
of preaching you to please use
hypothesis
um I know that uh you know sometimes I
feel catches and it's not always 100
like you must do it
um something you have to think about
when you use hypothesis
um
there's always a trade-off
uh one thing that uh why hypothesis is
not even more popular than what it is
right now is that tests can be slower if
you have a massive Library like it's
like you learn so
uh because then you have to generate a
lot of strategies and you have to
this is not even easy to write the test
anymore because uh you can use The
Ghostwriter to help you a little bit but
sometimes you still have fine tune the
strategy and stuff so
it will be a lot of work and a test can
be even slower because instead of having
like free cases to test
and the January them a few hypothesis so
I could be slower
thank you
so also tests can be harder to
understand what it means is that
in a for example I instead of using
hypothesis I use high test of
parameterize so in parameter rice is
very straightforward I have two input X
and Y so X is one two three Y is three
two one so it's like you know you see
the very straightforward and plus the
case you know all this stuff
um but for hypothesis you you don't
write it out you're just like oh X is an
integer Y is an integer and what what is
tested I I'm not sure but I just trust
hypothesis do it and uh it could be
difficult for someone to like want to
look at the cases by cases right
you can actually using hypothesis to say
that I definitely need to test for
example X to be 0 and Y to zero right I
want it that's what I definitely should
have to test you can you can do that but
if you're just writing it like what I've
shown you earlier just using strategies
then that would be more hidden what I've
done
um also
use typing on your code you can't really
use The Ghostwriter to the fullest
because what goes right here would tell
you so instead of
um so instead of like oh I use the
strategy as test right so this bit what
hypothesis we say is like using nothing
which is definitely well you you need to
test something right it's not testing
nothing so you have to find the strategy
and replace the nothing here yourself
so it's the not the most efficient way
if you're using it
oh I ended for abruptly sorry about that
so
um yeah so that's you have to think
about when you use hypothesis and
um but I think it generally like uh give
it a try if you have for example when
you just started a small project the
code base is still small try to see if
it helps try if it save your time if you
get used to it maybe you would love to
use it more
so um that's it from about hypothesis
last slice is about the online
conference high javascon is happening at
the end of this month I know it's the
Thanksgiving weekend but if you have
nothing else to do if you're sitting at
home this is the perfect way of uh
spending your holiday and
um and it's free it is free right just
sit on the couch and swim and you can
learn python okay so that's the end of
this talk thank you so much
[Applause]
I think um a little time for questions I
know there was one question at least no
okay
um
how many different things because I can
imagine
um
depending on how much
you want to have at the budget is
investing it's like okay five seconds
two things versus like try a thousand
different kinds of
things yeah so actually
um
um you will see that for some for
strategy they actually doesn't go too
crazy about like it would because the
strategy has been written and has been
tested by a lot of different Engineers
so for example I can tell you the
integer I think they test oh no the
string the the test that is here it has
the empty string it has maybe string
with one character and then spraying
with two characters and biggest one and
two puzzle is just assume that oh two
plus one also positive like but it won't
test infinite amount of things
um of course you get a challenge yet of
course you can think that like all this
strategy is not good you can either
customize it or you can even improve the
strategy and you know make a pull
request to change it for everybody else
but
um yeah but like for simple things it's
already designed that like oh I'm not
randomly testing many many things but
I'm testing
that's why it's called strategy it's
like picking the things to test that
it's more promised to overlook
um but yeah then that's like strategy is
a very complicated topic I think like
for an introductory talk like I'm going
to detail but uh definitely check out
the documentation check it out yourself
and yeah
with
okay so I'm curious why not
well I'm I'm just like I'm not like
blindly saying that you must use corner
right
well we can you can also you know well
even if you're using containers you play
with some things right so you can either
uh you know honey install or you can
probably store it I think the main
difference is that context using the
icon of reposal is like more secure and
stuff so
um yeah I I'm not like crazy saying like
you must use something yeah yeah
so for the round trip test does it test
for each single trip so for example
decode and impulse what if like in code
just returned the exact copy of your
input and your decode also return the
exact uh copy of your of your input does
that would that would that pass the test
or fail the test so you mean the round
trip for example in an example here if I
if I write another anchor and vehicle
and it's just like return what whatever
it is to do nothing it was it was uh
it was to work unless you know if
because this the thing is the public
here is that when it's an empty train it
will it would have oh I think it's
because it returns something that is
like uh it's not been defined or
something because of the check I I
haven't gone into detail but the problem
is that because when it's empty training
then like basically something happened
that some variable is not defined
somehow so if you just like do nothing I
think the the chance of making a mistake
is very low and I think that you would
pass on the test because well it does
nothing so it's perfect in that case it
doesn't know that it doesn't do nothing
yeah I guess what I meant is that does
it have whether in code gave you the
exact the expected output or would it
only test it after the two functions
packing yeah in that case in that case
for example Json Json knows and Json
dollars right that's all we we know
about that so it's easier to explain so
the hypnosis doesn't check that like oh
you have a string and a dictionary and
you put in the Json laws uh data Downs
does it come out as a perfect correct
pause Json string no it doesn't uh it's
just you know the ghost right here just
kind of taken some Shortcut that if you
encode and decode it will go back to
what it was if both of them are wrong if
both of them kind of roll at the same
time that it makes it go back to the
original it won't pick it up with the
round trip so that's some blind spot in
there
yeah it's not perfect if you want to
check with